oh man okay go ahead gary
uh hey everybody it's gary vaynerchuk uh
i had to transfer to a car so i haven't
done a lot of these lives as you know
in this environment so my partner in
crime who usually drives it anyways
who being the head of the president of
vayner commerce and i are excited to be
here
uh i may chop in and out because i know
i'm driving down a path that doesn't
have great internet
um but we're really excited about
another coffee and commerce and uh we
have two incredible
guests today and uh zubeen take it away
thanks gary um yup really happy to be
with everybody today
we've got uh to start off we've got
the co-founder of apartment to be alex
back one of my favorite clients a
gentleman a scholar and we are
absolutely enamored to have them on
today alex thanks for joining us
well you are i mean gary just i mean
he's going to respond here oh there he
goes
i'm here i'm here uh thank you so much
for having me um
yes i'm the co-founder and ceo of
apartment 2b we are a furniture brand
that lives online only
been around since 2010 so uh we had some
very interesting beginnings as you may
imagine in the e-comm space selling
furniture
pretty much at that time everybody would
tell you that you were crazy to do that
um now furniture brands like us are
somewhat a dime a dozen
and uh it's been an interesting road i
need a
wave to ride to just jump right in
because i want to bring tons of value
internet only do you expect in the
history of your company
to be in a place where you may have some
brick and mortar as brick and mortar
probably goes through heavy transition
over this next
two to three years do you envision
experiential
what i would call brick and mortar 3.0
of the future is that on your mind
at all yeah absolutely i think the word
is experiential
we're not looking for it as a revenue
stream it would just be sort of like a
flagship
we talked about it forever yeah we've
had pop-ups in the past
early on we did a few in los angeles
where we're based and you know we've
looked at retail spaces over the years
looking for that right opportunity um
there's
i think there's a lot of value in
something like that for a brand like
ours even if no one gets a visit
just having that presence is something
that people
are drawn to alex
talk to us a little bit about getting
started right so
a lot of the advice that entrepreneurs
get around starting a direct to consumer
digitally native brand is pick products
that are um certainly not too expensive
right like a lot of the products that
you see online
average product prices like 35 to 50
dollars
the products are super lightweight so
they can ship easily
and you decided to go completely the
other direction and
select furniture that's incredibly heavy
to ship
and price points are higher and yet when
we
talk to clients customers of yours etc
they're getting these things within days
um they're super happy about it how did
you decide to even do this and how did
you succeed at doing it
well it's interesting because that would
be the biggest barrier to entry when
starting an online furniture business
that theoretically would serve the
entire nation
originally we started the concept was to
live in los angeles only
and to kind of tackle one marketplace at
a time
we did that for a couple of years and
the interest was just
growing and growing and my business
partner matt herman and i we were
we were very just enamored by all of the
attention we were getting i just figured
we'd
you know open up the floodgates we did
that in 2013
and that's when our business went like
this orders coming in from every
bit of the country so we really just had
to adapt on the fly the
the the demand was there and we just
needed to figure it out
a lot of bumps in the road along the way
as you can imagine but
um i think i think it it's actually a
lot more of a well-oiled machine these
days than
than one might expect so i think
actually you know 10 years of operating
you know actually you know for you to be
alive 10 years like
i think people take entrepreneurship for
granted like being alive 10 years later
is a remarkable feat
and it's funny i when you just said that
i'm sorry to jump in
i actually think it's wildly well oiled
at this point
from two standpoints things that you've
actually accomplished
and things that you know are completely
[ __ ] up that you can't wait to fix at
some point
because you have so much context of the
120 months of being into the game
true 100 that's what i live i mean
you know one of our big things i think
one of the biggest things
that's made it successful is the fact
that we got in early and we're able to
figure out the kinks
we already were in the furniture
industry before we got into this so
that gave us a tremendous advantage to
be able to solve some of the issues
the logistical uh nightmares that that
may arise
in the furniture industry and then being
an operator of this specific business
for the last 10 years
like i always say to my team there's not
a problem we haven't seen before we know
how to solve
pretty much pattern recognition even if
you
haven't seen exactly it's a kissing
cousin of something you saw three years
ago
in this market i mean that you know we
were in an internal meeting today about
my speed it's only because i'm now at 44
years old
38 years into truly and call it 22 if
you don't want to take my childhood
though i learned everything there 22
years into so much pattern recognition
it might not be the same thing but it's
the same thing you agree alex
100 i mean it's um
pattern recognition is not something
that i've like a term that i've thought
of before or is on my mind
on a regular basis that's exactly what
it is just knowing
exactly how to address something make
quick decisions
um for a lot of us
young talented you know what you don't
know is how much experience matters like
cobit hits
and i go directly into recession 08
i go directly into 9 11 which in a lot
of ways had
comps i go directly into other things
that i didn't live but i lived through
the eyes of my great grandparents and
grandparents of
war you know like real stuff not kidding
and so
you know i you know i think and back to
like adversity being
such a good thing for kids yet we've
taken it away i also was a poor student
had a lot of adversity
so covet felt normal if that makes sense
sure
and you know one thing we always talk
about is apartment 2b was started on the
heels of a recession
um my business partner has this great
story he was living in a
fat house in the hollywood hills um
ended up losing his job because of the
2008
situation and that's kind of what
apartment 2b was born of
people downsizing their lives moving
into apartments totally
getting out of their houses moving
towards the cities looking for work
looking for a new hope
um so to me it always sort of seemed
like opportunity maybe not like the
first
few weeks but quickly it seemed evident
that this was a big
opportunistic moment for us and our
industry has
experienced ridiculous growth in the
last few months
insane like impossible to keep up with
type stuff
and i think there are two areas here
that
you have an incredibly interesting
perspective on that you can add a lot of
value on
so one side of it is what you mentioned
earlier where you started as a
local business it's just that you
deployed online
and then it grew and then you took it
national so what we're seeing a lot of
these days
and a lot of people that reach out and
want support and advice and whatnot
are local small businesses that want to
figure out how do they
get online with the intention of
eventually being able to fulfill
orders across the country so can you
kind of break that down for the audience
and talk about
what it took and what it takes now right
because what it took then is different
now like if you're giving someone advice
right now they've got a small business
uh in a local arena how do they actually
successfully
take that online and then from there how
do they even start to think about
national well it's interesting i think
you know logic would tell you that it's
really you know operating an online
local
retail entity is quite similar to
running a brick and mortar local retail
entity
there are a few key differences i think
the biggest one
is how is marketing how do you get your
customers
um into the door into the storefront if
there is no storefront
and i think you know for us early on
we leveraged a lot of kind of local
whatever it is these days would be local
influencers local
publications a lot of local events
pop-ups like i said before
so i think that was a major thing for us
to just get
a little bit of a foothold in the la
market before
taking it elsewhere um and online you
know i mean there's so many
there's so many sites that have you know
restrictions on
where people can buy and i think back
then it was very difficult
to have that messaging uh with the tools
that we had
uh technologically and just from totally
familiar but these days i think people
can really
do a good job of that and not lose too
much ground or confidence and
customer confidence when they tell oh
sorry we can't shift to your area so i
think it's very very
very yeah to start small especially with
these larger
larger pieces or larger ticket items
that carry a lot of liability
alex alex because i know i'm going i
thinking yeah i'm looking at the
neighborhood
i think i'm going to lose quite a bit
here so i'm going to get this last
question how are you
zoopian takes over um i'm just driving
in new york but there's just pockets um
what's the because i want to bring value
to who's watching what's the most
you know interesting uh opportunity on
the consumer level
that you see from a execution standpoint
within marketing
to acquire new customers is there any
channels or any executions that really
have your attention right now
i think well there's i have two answers
to that
one the social media space is still
still untapped and i think what i
personally how i've seen it grow over
the last three or four years
has been ridiculous um we have a lot of
eggs in that basket
and it's k and it continues to kind of
evolve and and change course but still
wildly successful i mean that's where
people
are spending their time we all know that
the the space that i think maybe doesn't
get a fair shake
because it's a little bit difficult to
understand and a bit like the wild west
is the affiliate marketing space and for
for us we're a customer partner
i'm sorry i was just you know what i'm
even
i'm like the guy i i think i'm under
tapping that keep going
yeah i think the affiliate space is you
know it can be real goofy there's a lot
of poaching especially
in our industry our sales cycles like
two to three weeks so people will
look for apartment 2b coupon codes
before
uh finalizing their purchase and you
know you have to be really careful about
who you affiliate with
however we've gotten a lot amazing every
month week after week
mentions from people in our in our space
apartment therapy
hdtv domino the major editorial players
they want to pay to play and either you
can go with like a huge
editorial spread and spend 50 grand or
you can go
the affiliate route and just compensate
them if sales are generated
well and and so let's lean on that last
part if sales are generated so
one of the things that kind of budding
entrepreneurs are going to run into
um that we we've seen obviously those of
us that have run
media and growth for a number of years
is attribution right
you get really excited you start running
google ads you run facebook you're on
tick tock snap
you've got affiliates going you look at
the first five days of the month and
each of them combined report
two hundred thousand dollars in revenue
and you're like [ __ ] i only have fifty
thousand dollars in my shopify store
that's an attribution problem
everybody's taking credit or multiple
places are taking credit
how do you handle affiliate attribution
yes if my my team that's watching right
now
we're smiling because half of our
affiliate marketing calls are about
attribution and um keeping it clean i
think it needs to be heavily watched
over
um but taking a step back from that you
know
online attribution these days it's
almost impossible to follow we've tried
various tools
um and applications that are meant to
like track that and really um keep that
you know policed and clean for you and
give you a really accurate picture
it's very very difficult especially for
a business like us
where it's not an immediate purchase
just we're coming back to our site
there's
multiple site visits for every single
customer
um so for us i think our approach is
somewhat applicable to other industries
as well
which is to look at it as a blend um you
want to set
you know set an roi that you're
comfortable with um
obviously that takes time to establish
that but it's math and you know most
people can figure it out after some time
and once you establish that then you
sort of work backwards you kind of add
pieces to the puzzle take them away
move things around as you see fit to
make sure that you're hitting your
numbers and overall
you know alex what you're talking about
is iterating because that's real life
and too many people want perfection up
front and end up never doing [ __ ]
because you're practically operating and
a lot of people play in school
or thesis or executive role not
operating role well the good thing about
it the
luxury and disadvantage that we have is
our long sales cycle
and and i think it's forced us to do
this we don't like
not knowing where our sales are coming
from or a customer journey
uh you know the entire all the steps of
our customer journey but
it it at least helps to know that well
we'll never know
because if they're going on a three-week
process you can't track everything
there's
also multiple decision makers usually
involved in a furniture purchase so
that's something to consider as well
um so we've sort of backdoored our way
into this strategy but i appreciate it
yet you know it's one of the things that
we really harp on in terms of
our clients and and the the gentleman
that'll join us next uh
nate champion our new chief growth
officer um
one of the reasons we brought him on
board is because we kind of we saw
completely eye to eye in terms of growth
and the fact that
to gary's point there's no perfection in
this you're not going to go and say this
is exactly what's going to happen and
this is what's going to happen
the key is unlike
yesteryear when old companies would
choose one path and go down that path
for a year to try to get results
you choose a few paths and then you
iterate as quickly as you can with your
creative your channel this that the
other
to figure out what works and companies
that can do that
fast and do that effectively are the
ones that succeed because ultimately
they're trying to find right
as opposed to assuming they know what's
right and i think that's kind of what
you're
what you're getting at alex this is what
you guys have been able to do
absolutely i think us being nimble
over the last 10 years has been one of
the biggest
advantages to our business um
changing quickly making decisions it
quickly based on
data and um you know and and facts i
think
has been tremendously valuable to us
especially in the last few months
the last few months have thrown
everybody so many curveballs i'm sure
you guys have discussed this before you
know previous ones of these
um but us being nimble and being able to
change our entire marketing campaign for
the following week
has been one of the tremendous uh gifts
that we've been given simply because
we're inherently nimble um
in our company and and approach it from
a boutique kind of
standpoint yeah absolutely um alex
one question for you and then we're
gonna go to nate and then we'll bring
you back on for questions
uh from the audience one quick question
for you to end it what has been the most
surprising thing that's occurred for
apartment to be
uh over the last few months that was
unexpected or will
potentially be a surprise and something
that people can learn from they're
listening in
i i think just the just in general the
tremendous
growth that we've experienced um even in
light of
many of the you know kind of outside of
the kova 19 situation
the other kind of social roller coaster
that we've been on
um societally over the last few months
politically
it our industry has remained incredibly
stable
and incredibly growth driven and that
has been
i mean the amount that it has grown has
been the biggest surprise
i think it's just very it's very
interesting it makes sense if you think
about it
everybody's sitting at home complaining
about their furniture to their
significant other all right fine
go ahead buy something new but it's also
it's it's it's great it's a really it's
a blessing but it's it's
very very interesting and surprising at
the same time who would have guessed
absolutely alex thank you for that alex
we'll have you back on about 10-15
minutes
to everyone in the audience thank you
alex enter your questions
and we'll address them at the end and
now we will introduce our new chief
growth officer
mr nate champion there he is
gentlemen what's happening what's good
how you doing as everybody can tell the
reason we
hired nate was looks but he also happens
to be good
at growth yeah that's not what we were
looking for but
just ended up happening uh nate let's
talk about
um i'll give you yeah i'll give you a
quick rundown hopefully i don't bore
anyone the uh
i think i'll go back to so in college i
was an econ major i think that was
relatively
rare major and then i went into economic
consulting which was a really rare
career path
super dorky if you want to be a vp above
your phd
i worked in the antitrust department and
crazy work that we were doing so we
worked basically it was like a huge
merger
acquisition happens think like office
max and staples or
whole foods and wild oats and the
department of justice comes in says hey
we think this could be
really bad for competition you could
raise prices we get hired on behalf of
lawyers to basically
put all the pieces of data together
analyze it and say
hey this is good or bad for competition
insanely large disparate data sets
um takes an insane amount of work just
to even
make it one holistic view of data and
then two to analyze it and run
regression to do all this crazy
complicated stuff
that that i could not do i spent six
years doing that
and learning a ton in terms of um
understanding data respecting data
almost like fearing data
and understanding really what you can
and cannot do with data um i remember
when i was working there i was like man
what the hell am i going to do
with my career like this is definitely
not what i'm doing the rest of my life i
don't want my phd
but looking back i think that was really
like a launching pad in terms of
e-commerce because so much of it d2c is
data-driven and so
after six years i went and did what what
some people do when they have no idea
what they want to do i went to business
school
um unlike a lot of business school
people i actually didn't i didn't love
business school i don't i don't feel
like i learned a lot i do
feel like i i was able to get a lot of
exposure to like cool ideas and startups
and and learn that that was the path i
wanted to do
um it cost a lot of money for me to to
learn that um
going to business school but um yeah i
spent some time in brand management
following like a more traditional career
path in my summer internship i didn't
love it it was a little slow-moving
once it started very slow okay yeah so
slow
uh not that it's it's no hold on let's
knowing who's watching like
a lot of impressionable curious trying
to figure out their
life like right now could be a really
funny moment to bring a lot of value and
really just one kid
getting impacted would be a huge coup
for all of us i'm sure
explain to them how slow in context
to like start up land or fast
environments
yeah so i'll give you an example so my
my summer internship was for a huge
uh it was actually cpg brands within a
pharmaceutical company so even more red
tape added to the equation even smaller
otc over the counter yeah um and so i
got a really sexy product i got wart
remover for the summer and i was tasked
with understanding like why we were
losing market share
within the space and why the whole space
was losing market share i did all these
crazy announcements it was actually kind
of a fun project to think about and try
and figure out
i remember at the end i presented get
award by the way
how do you get one the truth like i i'm
yeah i'm like genuinely i have no idea
how does one get award
it's it's a virus like skin-to-skin
contact type deal if i remember
correctly
you know i still think if i pick up a
frog i'm getting one
you gotta kiss the frog dude you can
touch it you know what's funny i still
have a scar
on my head i actually had one when i was
little on my on my
in on my hand and i literally bit it off
like that's how i decide it took me like
a year
that was so some people were solving it
by like using duct tape and stuff
i remember when i was looking keep going
sorry
yeah so anyway i came up with all these
cool strategies i had to present it to
like a bunch of people big weeks at the
company
i remember one of them that that drove
me like i was analyzing our food
then and i had figured out okay our tv
spend actually does nothing to drive
sales
so in q4 we had a bunch we had millions
of dollars scheduled for tv spend
and we were in like q2 or something so i
was like all right guys
um as part of the presentation i'm going
to throw in here like rip out the tv
spend let's reinvest it into these
channels that actually perform and drive
sales
i remember my boss was like nate like we
can't show that
to the bigwigs they're going to take the
money and invest it somewhere else
they're going to think we're doing a
horrible job they're not going to
understand why we ever invested in tv
and i was just like man like this is
this is brutal you guys don't actually
want to action on any of the data that
you're seeing and then all the other
ideas were like
so much red tape to go through and so
impossible to just execute on it it
would be like two years
to execute one of these things and
compared to a startup
um same day like i find something it's
like
dude i think we can launch a new landing
page and increase conversion a little
bit
it's up in two hours and there you go
and so i think that um the speed to
execution and the ability to learn
much quicker to me was was so much more
fun than
than slowly planning and strategizing
the space that and
and the ability not to have to worry
that you're going to offend
someone or something that was done
before you right
like your point the reason they didn't
want to stop doing television is because
they're
like someone's going to tell me why have
i been doing television for so long
totally yeah and i think that's the
beauty of growth marketing and an
ultrasound
is like what is the truth and how do you
action on that truth and learn
and just keep that cycle going so um
yeah that's really what got me involved
in startups like i said it was a very
expensive
lesson to learn by going to business
school but um one that i'm i'm
definitely grateful for i think one of
the things just for the audience to take
home
not being in meetings for those of you
basically everyone in the audience who
isn't in meetings with gary frequently
one of the things that you recognize
when you are in meetings with him
is a lot of what he really focuses in on
is changing bad behavior recognizing it
and then trying to influence that bad
behavior
so and it's it's bad for now right it
could have been good before
but the reality is it's bad for now and
when and it might be bad and it might be
bad i mean
ever i cannot wait cannot wait
to 13 to 16 years from now putting out
content making fun of everything
that i hold near and dear today but
that's the point
because it evolves and yet they don't
but but jerry rice would not be the best
receiver in football today
yeah he's the goat but
he would not go on the field right now
and dominate and that's just the way it
is
and that inherently is one of the
advantages that everybody listing in
right now
who doesn't have the baggage of bad
decisions with them
that's the advantage they have that you
can go out there
do your research figure out how to do
things the right way which is part of
why we have the show right like we want
to teach people
not how alex did it before or how nate
did it before
but rather how they think and how they
get to the conclusion that they do
so that you can leverage that you can
start thinking that way and make the
best decision for yourself today
not based on a decision somebody else
made before but how they made the
decision before
anyway sorry nate we went on a uh
complete random rant
bring us and real quick i just want to
say welcome on board
i'm super obsessed as you know i i'm
bouncing off anyway schedule time i
i'm glad i didn't chop off uh and uh
have a great rest of the show zubin
thank you
thanks gary so nate
bring us to freshly and and talk to us a
little bit so just to kind of recap for
everybody
and then one of the reasons why i was so
impressed with nate
um as i mentioned at the onset of this
around how we see growth
is because of the fact that his
foundation
was in finance and data and then
realizing that a lot of the data isn't
actionable and then when he tried to
make it actionable
in some cases he wasn't able to but the
fact that
we see eye to eye on that with the rest
of the team as well in terms of it being
able to build growth models and think
about
an organization's growth with
the proper balance of data intuition and
the quant qual balance of
quantifying something and qualitatively
looking at it and understanding
how the two work hand in hand and not
that they're separate is really critical
to success yes you've got data that you
can look at you've got all the analytics
reports but your ability
to be able to actually trust your gut
trust what you want to do
put it out there do it as quickly as you
can and then look at the results and let
those results
influence what you're doing is really
critical so i just want
nate to give us a couple of minutes
about his experience at freshly
that's had phenomenal growth um since
the beginning since nate's been there
um and then we'll bring alex back and
start answering some of your questions
cool yeah so i was uh fortunate enough i
was the first tire back at freshly in
in 2015. um pre-series a so they had
already there were people in the kitchen
cooking meals and stuff but the ceo i
just moved to new york when i joined it
was just myself and the ceo
doing the the marketing and kind of
business side of
freshly and i think uh food was the
perfect place so i think
growth marketing in general a startup in
general is is a great way to
to learn about a business but also add
food on top of it d to seafood
prepared d to seafood and you add so
much complexity
and the margins are so tight that growth
marketing acquisition retention becomes
so huge and so important and so i think
it was really the perfect environment
for me to to learn about this stuff
because the stakes were so high and so
um yeah i had a blast i mean man in the
beginning we were we were lucky to get
to
a million meals a year uh this year
probably doing more like 40 million
um we were on the deloitte's like
fastest 500 i think we were number 70 in
the in the fastest growing companies
um it's been a wild ride man it's it's
it's been absolutely crazy and yeah to
your point it's
it's uh it really starts at the top so
the ceo is a very smart
guy very data driven guy and i think he
understood exactly what you're talking
about and it trickles down and so you've
got a team and a culture who really
believes in
in this growth mindset and this really
building these loops that allow you to
grow a company quicker than you
otherwise would
and so i think it becomes a volume game
of saying like hey let's put this out in
the world
let's analyze it let's see if it works
the stuff that works scale it the stuff
that does not work
turn it off building systems around that
so you can get to that answer
quicker and faster um leveraging
technology as you know
this is a big reason why i'm joining
vayner is because
you guys uh really take this holistic
approach to growth you're not just
optimizing
on advertising trying to minimize cac
and saying we do a great job at that
you're saying
we do a great job at everything we think
about acquisition we think about
retention we think about the tech stack
which
really at the end of the day it's all
the same stuff if you if you deep dive
into retention it ends up being an
acquisition question if you deep dive
into acquisition it ends up being a
retention question um so yeah i uh
i'm pumped to be here man i'm i'm on day
five but i'm i feel like i've been here
for five years already
we're pumped to be here and your last
name is champion so [ __ ] yeah
uh nate one more question for you that i
think is really important
as well for the audience and i promise
to bring alex back back
um retention when you and i first
met when we talked about media growth
direct to consumer growth etc
one of the things that you uh mentioned
and if there was like a word cloud for
our conversation
the biggest word would have been
retention uh talk to us a little bit
about how you see retention
because so many companies so many people
that are out there right now they start
a brand they're doing everything
everybody's focused on uh acquisition
and so
just for everyone's identification
you've got three parts at a very high
level of a funnel right
you've got the acquisition side and that
has its own upper final lower funnel mid
funnel
you acquire the customer to your site
then there's a conversion which is like
your site side of things and they buy
from you
and then there's retention and so many
brands over the last five ten years
have focused on acquisition and
conversion and retention has been like a
secondary tertiary thing like oh now we
kind of need to
get our customers to buy from us again
why is it that you put so much emphasis
into retention
even at the onset of acquisition well so
i mean i would say we did the same thing
at freshly where we raised our series a
grow grow grow heavy discounts every
channel you could possibly think of even
the crappy ones and then you start to
say wow my retention is going down
and i think once you start thinking
about retention you realize that
retention
is a hugely difficult problem to one
understand and to
solve as a result of that so i think not
that acquisition is easy but it's
an easier game to play and optimize
around an ad to a conversion
retention is really like everything from
the ad that i see
to the experience that i have on site to
the post purchase
onboarding sequence to the emails that i
receive to the customer service that i
have to the inbox experience
everything is retention and so i think
um
when you realize how hard it is to
understand you kind of start to realize
why so many companies don't really
know how to piece it together and think
about it and really it's it's a massive
data question
and so i think um tons and tons of
low-hanging fruit i have consulted uh
for so many brands on the retention side
of business where they just don't know
even what to look at what are the right
kpis to look at um
what should they be what's like a good
benchmark and so i think
there's so much low hanging fruit you've
already done the work of acquiring this
customer
most likely paying to acquire this
customer paying for the eyeballs
testing getting them to convert and now
how do you optimize that and monetize it
even further and so i think
um yeah it's just a really really
difficult
uh question to solve it's kind of like
death by a thousand cuts type deal
and so um piecing that together and then
like i said earlier like it really does
come back to acquisition at some point
you say hey my retention is actually
best by this
channel at this discount rate and you
start
pulling those levers and that's that's
again really where like
thinking about growth holistically
because when you have these disparate
teams and acquisition team and a
retention team and a product team
for sure operating in silos you don't
get to piece all that together and say
hey dude
your facebook campaigns that run this
specific campaign on this specific plan
with this specific discount
might give you a really low acquisition
cost but it's actually horrible
retention so let's turn that off
scale this one scale this one um
yeah and another way of kind of putting
what you're mentioning i think for the
audience is that look
acquisition you're running ads you're
doing all this stuff at the the
the funnel to get people to your site
experience whether you're selling amazon
you're selling direct to consumer on
your dot com whatever it is
you want to optimize that experience so
they buy on your com
and you want to make sure that they can
buy multiple products often frequent etc
but retention is the real business i
think is what nate's talking about here
if you had a physical business it would
be the experience someone gets talking
to your customer service team
how they feel about your brand all those
real
things that are often overlooked because
people are looking at just selling a
product right and they're thinking about
how am i going to sell this product
spend the least amount of money selling
this thing and growing but
the reality of that and the reality of a
lot of this
is that we don't have to go too far
to look at direct-to-consumer businesses
that succeed we should look at
other businesses historically that have
succeeded and again
i want to emphasize that it's not about
how they do things but it's about what
they care about and when there's a
customer-centric
mentality in that organization when they
feel like
we have to make sure our customers are
happy and not happy because they're
expected to be happy
or that they're expecting something from
us but how do we surprise and delight
them if we're going to sell them a
product how do we add something in there
that's
they weren't expecting i keep
referencing this and i think it's just
so
important for people to understand when
any of us
uh listening in um we used to go to the
store whatever you buy cologne you buy
perfume you buy lotion
macy's nordstrom whatnot one of the best
parts of that experience for many people
were the samples they gave you
you weren't expecting them but you got
those samples and it's what can you do
that's unexpected to elevate that
experience
so when you buy from apartment 2b you're
gonna go tell five of your friends
[ __ ] man this came faster than i
expected it was a great experience they
followed up with me
et cetera et cetera et cetera and i
think those are the things
that many brands that exist today as
well as ones that are starting
aren't putting enough emphasis into
which are the real reasons why somebody
cares about the brand
which has to do with the product the
customer service the authenticity
the the real part of that business
alex anything out there well yes i think
i think we're very strong in a lot of
those areas but in our industry
specifically these kind of larger ticket
items where you're not buying
a sofa every single year it can sort of
muddy the waters
strategically when it comes to
developing a retention plan that that
makes sense
and you're right nate everything you
said about brands being so overly
focused on acquisition
um we i mean we live that you know um
it's fun yeah i think that
oh good good no i think for
like you look at real estate right um
real estate agents
real estate agents aren't selling you
homes every day but the really good ones
their retention play is obviously that
they'll sell another home to you in five
to seven years or whatever that cycle is
but their retention play is that you're
gonna go tell five other people about
that experience
and and and and they're gonna be able to
retain you and
your circle and i think that's the same
for like apartment 2b it's not about
me buying and retaining me i'll think
about them again when i buy in the
future but it's more a matter of
my circle and me sharing within my
circle and then
you start looking at retention not as me
but who i
influence and and retaining that group
if you will
yeah if that were to be referred to as
sort of indirect retention i think we do
a very good job of that and that's a
huge part of how we built our brand
absolutely expert you know marketers and
advertisers from day one
but the word of mouth spreading of
apartment to be and the good experiences
and great furniture the good product
that people have received from us i
think has been invaluable so it's a
great point
awesome let's jump into questions
gentlemen niles clark
asks what percentage of overall
marketing budget is allocated to one
hundred percent
brand spend
you want to take the time alex sure yeah
for us um
i think just in general one has to sort
of feel it out
and i think this might be an industry
specific
sort of a thing um you know for us
our our our customers are generally
looking for there's there's a
convenience aspect and there is
um there's there's something to be said
for
a need that needs to be serviced
and those those customers may need to be
marketed to a bit more directly
than some others that you may be
romancing for a longer period of time i
think
so for us i think the percentage of you
know brand and marketing exploits
just pure brand brand awareness type
stuff is
is a lot lower than maybe other
industries that
are a little bit more into the romance
um
we have a product that fulfills a need
for individuals and
you know we sort of kind of we're pretty
aggressive
in that regard but we do pay a lot of
attention we always
have to the brand and really tried to do
some interesting things to
differentiate ourselves as a furniture
retailer from
the many marketplaces and faceless
brands in in our space so i think it's
very important
well and i think what's what's perhaps
um a good takeaway for those
that are listening in is the fact that
very few organizations
can spend money on 100 brand
right you're starting out or even if
you're growing you can't spend 100 brand
but what apartment 2b does and the ones
that are really successful doing this
they integrate brand throughout the
experience and one of the things that
gary talks about often is that lower
funnel
and the fact that that lower funnel is
so focused on
conversion meaning i see this ad about a
lifestyle
generally speaking whatever i'm like oh
that's interesting about a nice looking
living room and i click to it
and then i start looking at a few
products and then i start seeing more
product driven ads mid funnel
and then when i actually go to one
product then i'm just getting retargeted
to literally just buy that product
without much brand influence in there
and it's really at that point where you
can introduce brand
and flip this thing on its head and not
think about hey i'm going to go brand
to hybrid a brand product to straight
product
but i think again what's really
important is not necessarily
to allocate percentage of spend for 100
brand
but integrate brand 100 throughout your
spend
cool next question brandon bell well
this is he
directing it at nate so we're going to
go to nate nate recent college right
here
going into big four consulting i want to
work in a startup growth space for my
career
what can i learn now that will make me
an amazing ecomm growth consultant
okay so i think uh and this is obviously
biased from my own experience but
like i said earlier i think having a
deep understanding of data and
and what's a lot of people might say
like yeah i'm a data driven marketer and
i've worked with
i've worked with a lot of marketers
who've said that and i
promise you 99.9 percent of them are are
not
and like testing a b testing a subject
line is not
data driven i'm talking like hardcore
you can write sql code
you can work with massive data sets um
you can build cohort retention
waterfalls
you you truly understand and respect
data i think as a
as a core as like a foundation i think
really gives you a massive massive head
start
over everyone else working in the growth
space because typically what you have is
more traditional marketers who like are
data driven but
not really and they can't do all that
stuff or you have a data scientist
who can do all that stuff but they don't
understand what they should be looking
for or how it can
whatever insights are extracted can be
launched in a marketing campaign and so
i think when you have both of those
things you can move so much faster and
get so much more done
with with way fewer people
and really just crank man and so i think
i think from my my end i would say
data understanding for sure um taking
like a sequel course or something
and then another great resource that i
really like it's kind of expensive but
you might be able to
figure something out with work is uh
reforge has some really good
um brian balfour and that that group
have
some really good uh resources about
growth and startups and e-commerce and
all that good stuff
brilliant and i want to apologize for
stephen colombia who in the comments
asked me to play some motivational sp
uh motivational tune on the pianos nate
was talking
next time we'll have the keyboard here
so i can just basically make a
soundtrack as we go
uh next question thank you for that nate
vanessa n
where do you draw the line if your
product works versus
needs better marketing and targeting
alex yeah that's an interesting
interesting question um you know
what that means to me or what that
brings up in my mind is kind of the
current period
that we're in we are a hundred percent
focused on keeping up with growth
growth and scale and not really able to
focus
on the next to do the interesting
really developing our product and our
brand the way that we're used to doing
we're focused on reacting versus being
proactive
so i think sometimes it can be difficult
and you don't always get to choose
um but i think
you know the proof is in the pudding
right i mean you you need to get
feedback
from customers i've always been
extremely deeply immersed
in in everything having to do with the
customer experience i read a lot
um and i think you get a sense of
whether something's really really
really working um and who you're who
you're reaching and who you're targeting
um
and if that's working as well can i add
something zubin please
um i think this is also kind of like a
product market
fit question and when i think about
product market fit it ultimately comes
down to retention so maybe your
acquisition costs are super high and you
might be asking this question saying
like do i need to be better at
targeting or copy or messaging or
whatever it is and
and uh more effectively convert people i
think if people are sticking around
and using the product ultimately that
answers your question of okay this is
this is a product that works now it
becomes a game of how do i get
more people to buy this product and
spend less money doing so and so i think
um as most things do in the e-commerce
world
uh i i think it comes back to a
retention question and then it becomes
okay how do i get better at acquisition
marketing
yeah that's fantastic advice and i think
that to
to to kind of recap that on two ends one
is
does your product work is there a market
fit for your product
um and and to alex and nate's points
that's something you've got to figure
out and i think as much as
we often pay too much attention to what
works versus what doesn't work
so you put out a lot of creative this
that the other you see what works
talk to those people try to engage with
those people who haven't purchased or
those people who've had a bad experience
understand why
um reach out to them set up chat on your
site so that you can actually speak to
people that are browsing your site
and and live connect with them and find
out why they're not purchasing it
because if the issue is that your
product is 50 bucks and it's costing you
75
to sell it well is there an opportunity
somebody buys it three times in in a
period of
four months in which case you can pay 75
so the whole
works thing is is there a market fit for
it
and if there is then are you pricing it
too high are you not
able to justify the acquisition costs
etc but really try to break that problem
down
so that it's not a matter of uh is this
going to work or not or am i going down
the wrong
path or not break those things up for
yourself so that you understand how to
make those decisions in terms of go no
go as you move forward
um brilliant guys all right billy smash
asks
how important is seo or google ads to be
on top spot
on a very niche product if you're a
startup
who's taking this one you are yeah
and then alex you can chime in um i
think
i think it depends so seo is one of
those things that you always wish that
you invested in
sooner because it's like more of a long
game and you don't really realize the
benefits of seo until
much later and so i've always found that
in every every startup that i've been a
part of it's like man i wish i started
this yesterday and so i would say seo
get started from the beginning start
thinking about that stuff
um google ads i would say it depends on
um
like if we're thinking about branded
search and and bidding on your own terms
like
whatever your brand name is i think if
nobody else is bidding on it then
absolutely not you should not be
spending on during the third
um if other people are then then it
becomes a data question how much does it
cost then for me to get the customer and
how much am i willing to pay and what's
my lifetime value
and then the non-non-branded stuff is
tricky so like if you're selling
like freshly for example if you're
selling prepared food you want to bid on
someone who searches for healthy meals
or is that like way too broad and it's
going to be super expensive for me to
convert someone
who searches for that again i think
that's more of a uh
a data question at the end of the day
but alex i would i would be interested
to hear what you have to say
well the niche product thing was was the
part that i found most interesting about
this question because
we there are some categories that we
covered that in the online space has
been over the last 10 years of very
niche product
furniture in general to be one one of
them um
but we'll often find you know analyzing
our organic search prowess and in
various
uh categories that we're like extremely
top-ranked
in a certain area and i think it's
important to number one be very aware
of of what your what data is coming back
as far as you know seo and search volume
and also react be able to react to that
there's also a correlation between the
seo and the paid
paid search um aspect as well i think
those two can run hand in hand when we
see an opportunity
in seo we often will try to exploit that
opportunity at google ads as well
to try to you know whether one thing for
instance for us to use a real example
uh sleeper sectionals that's sectional
sofas with a sleeper
huge item really heavy very rare to sort
of find
in general in the furniture market um
and we have a very strong program
in that specific area so we were
outranking all of our big competitors
matt the last couple of years
i think they've wised up to it or
everyone has kind of gotten into the
market a little bit more
but we had a sweet spot where we were
hitting them both on seo and we had some
great rankings and
also on paid search was a really really
um
heavy target for us in that specific
category that's awesome
so billy snacks it's very important
all right folks we got time for one last
question today
um please for all the other questions
you have uh
tweeted us we'll answer them for you um
just message us and we'll definitely get
to you uh join us next week as well but
in the meantime
one final question from over looting
personal question
how do you as a marketer determine the
tasks or activities that will end up
being the most relevant for business
growth
thank you um
i'm going to sound like broken record i
think it's ultimately a data question i
think as you do more and more marketing
you start to learn okay this is probably
going to have more of an impact than
this
recognition yeah but i think ultimately
it's just like
testing understanding the impact and
saying
okay i'm gonna go with the one that i
think can can drive the largest impact
um
so it sounds simple but i think that's i
think that's the game
and i'll piggyback on that by talking
about the the preemptive action to that
you have to make some gut decisions and
use
your own intuition and experience an
observation of what other people are
doing
to gain at least some semblance of a
strategic plan
and once you start that strategic plan
like nate said you've got to be all over
the data i think and that's been you
know very very valuable to us over the
years
thanks gents one last thing i'll add on
that i think
the key part of that question is
business growth and understanding what
that means to you
because in order to understand where you
want to spend your time you have to map
that to the outcomes that you're looking
for
so if your outcomes are top line revenue
your outcome might be
that you have a lot of revenue but you
need to cut costs what does business
growth mean for you
and then try to map out everything that
you do
to focus on achieving those milestones
against those outcomes and then
you'll realize that success and it won't
just be serendipitous
alex absolute pleasure to have you on so
good with you
nate welcome aboard for the rest of year
please uh reach out i'm sorry there are
a lot of questions
we wanted to answer unfortunately due to
the time we couldn't reach out to us
we'll get to you please join us next
week and in the meantime have a
wonderful weekend
thanks everyone thanks guys
see ya